meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
Werte medienvertreterinnen und
Medienvertreter ich darf Sie recht
herzlich hier heute am Heldenplatz in
Wien willkommen heißen an meiner Seite
darf ich begrüßen die
Verteidigungsministerin Claudia Tanner
den Militärkommandanten von Wien Herrn
Brigadier Kurt Wagner und direkt rechts
nemen mir den Regisseur Kurt ponkratz
Frau Verteidigungsministerin ich würde
sie um ihre Worte ersuchen vielen Dank
sehr geehrter Herr Militärkommandant
sehr geehrter Herr Professor ponkrat
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren der Medien
wie jedes Jahr dürfen wir Sie zur
Pressekonferenz vor dem Nationalfeiertag
hier an diesem geschichtsträchtigen Ort
begrüßen am heldtenplatz der Zeitzeuge
vieler Epochen in der österreichischen
Geschichte war Zeitzeuge im Dunkeln aber
auch durchus in schönen Momenten für
mich als Verteidigungsministerin ich
denke für uns alle gehören auf jeden
Fall die Feierlichkeiten und die
leistungchau unseres Bundesheeres rund
um den Nationalfeiertag zu den wirklich
besonders schönen Momenten aber der
Nationalfeiertag ist nicht nur ein Tag
des Feierns sondern auch ein Tag zum
nachdenken zum Nachdenken und zum etwas
in die Vergangenheit schauen zum
Nachdenken über die vielen Meilensteine
dieser zweiten Republik ganz an der
Spitze steht der Beschluss des
neutralitätsgesetzes ein Gesetz das bis
heute seine Wirkung nicht verloren hat
ein Gesetz das bis heute die Identität
und das Handeln unserer Republik prägt
und mitbestimmt ja und auf der anderen
Seite dürfen wir uns als
österreichisches Bundesheer unsere
Soldatinnen und Soldaten präsentieren
und ihr Können auch zeigen ganz
besonders dürfen wir uns als das
präsentieren was wir sind nämlich ein
Teil unserer Gesellschaft sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren der Nationalfeiertag
wird auch dieses Jahr wieder ein groß
Aufgebot an verschiedenen
Themenbereichen rund um das Bundesheer
am Heldenplatz und an anderen Orten auch
bieten ganz besonders wird aber schon
eines im Zentrum stehen nämlich alles
was mit der Sicherheitslage zu tun hat
das heißt wir werden selbstverständlich
die Sicherheitslage stündlich beobachten
und beurteilen und die entsprechenden
Sicherheitsmaßnahmen erhöhen und
verschärfen je nachdem wie das die Lage
auch erfordert wir haben auch wieder
etwas ganz Neues so wie jedes Jahr es
wird die wienpremiere unseres neuen
Hubschraubers des Leonardo AW 169 leihen
gezeigt werden wir werden einen ganz
besonderen IKT Container auch
präsentieren um auf Cyber Defense auch
hinzuweisen die endigkeiten die wir
haben und was mich besonders freut dass
wir eben auch tausend anzugelobende
Rekruten wieder hier am Heldenplatz
haben werden bei denen auch Rekrutinnen
dabei sind aber der Herr Brigadier
Wagner wird darauf dann noch genauer
eingehen der nationalfeierertag ist aber
auch ein Tag wo wir Danke sagen dürfen
danke unseren vielen Soldatinnen und
Soldaten die Tag für Tag ihr Bestes
geben zum Schutz Österreichs und unserer
Bevölkerung danke aber auch den
hunderten Bediensteten aus dem Kader
Miliz und Zivilbediensteten Stand zu
sagen den 1300 grundwertinern die dafür
sorgen dass diese beiden Tage mit
Sicherheit ein fulminantes Fest für uns
alle werden und das das auch sichtbar
wird dafür sorgt einer dem ich heute
ganz besonders danke sagen möchte
nämlich Professor pronkratz der es
alljährlich schafft diesen
Nationalfeiertag mit besonderen
Bildern denjenigen in die Wohnzimmer
nach Hause zu bringen vier Stunden lang
eine Übertragung mit wirklich besonderen
Bildern für diejenigen die leider nicht
hierher kommen können ein ganz großes
Dankeschön was ich habe gestern die das
militärmusikfestival noch einmal gesehen
auch im ORF zum zweiten Mal übertragen
sensationell diese Bilder die wir da
erlebt haben und die wir mit Sicherheit
dann auch am 26 Oktober erleben werden
ich möchte aber auch Herrn rusotzki
Dank sagen der auch wieder Filme
dementsprechend würdig in Szene setzen
wird also es werden durchaus
atemberaubende Aufnahmen werden sehr
gete Damen und Herren ein Tag des
Andenkens ein Tag des Feierns aber ohne
Zweifel auch ein dank ein Tag um Bilanz
zu ziehen Bilanz darüber was wir in den
letzten Monaten für unser Bundesheer für
unsere Soldatinnen Soldaten erreichen
konnten ich habe schon angesprochen den
neuen Hubschrauber sie wissen wir werden
ja 36 davon bekommen wir haben die
typenentscheidung getroffen in der
Nachfolge unseres Transport
Hubschraubers wir haben weitere Verbände
ausgestattet mit den neuen Uniformen
einige sehen wir hier schon davon und
laufend statten wir unsere Soldaten mit
neuem Gerät neuen Sturmgewehren neuen
radpanzern LKWs neuen Fahrzeugen aus wir
investieren auch in die Kasernen
Infrastruktur wir haben den
grundwerrdienst für Frauen geöffnet wir
haben für eine bessere Besoldung und
unsere grundwerdiiner Unteroffiziere und
Zivilbediensteten gesorgt für die
bessere Bezahlung bei den Offizieren da
werden wir auch weiter kämpfen nein
kämpfen müssen weil wir uns sehr Gerte
Damen und Herren eines nicht tun dürfen
wir dürfen uns nicht ausruhen auf dem
was wir erreicht haben wir müssen jeden
Tag weiter dafür arbeiten dass das
österreichische Bundesheer das wird was
sie alle was die Österreicherinnen und
Österreicher sich verdient haben aber
auch unsere Soldatinnen und Soldaten
sich verdient haben und es ist schon
eine große Freude gewesen das Budget
präsentieren zu dürfen letzte Woche wir
werden in den nächsten vier Jahren 18
Milliarden Euro für das bundesher zur
Verfügung haben für die Sicherheit
Österreichs zur Verfügung haben sie
wissen ja sehr viele unsereer
Soldatinnen und Soldaten mussten im
budgetären Bereich über Jahrzehnte sehr
vieles vermissen das ist keine
Wertschätzung die Wertschätzung die wird
es uns jetzt ermöglichen dass wir das
Bundesheer über unseren Aufbauplan 202
30 plus mit der Mission vorwärts
dorthinbringen wo eine moderne Armee
auch stehen sollte jahrzehntelange
Versäumnisse das geht nicht von einem
Tag auf den anderen die aufzuholen aber
wir sind auf einem guten Weg die Lücken
auch zu schließen die Lücken die viele
Jahre der Vernachlässigung unseres
Bundesheeres hinterlassen haben wir sind
zuversichtlich dass wir den Aufbauplan
2032 umsetzen werden und damit auch die
Aufgaben für die Österreicherinnen und
Österreicher noch besser erfüllen können
ich bin auch von einem überzeugt dass
das neue Gerät das wir auch hier dann
präsentieren können auch uns als bundesh
als Arbeitgeber attraktiver macht für
die jungen Österreicherinnen und
Österreicher der Nationalfeiertag ist
nicht nur ein Tag um das bundesher in
der Mitte der Gesellschaft zu
präsentieren und den Kontakt mit der
Bevölkerung zu stärken sondern vor allem
auch und das wollen wir ganz besonders
nutzen dass wir uns als aktiver
Arbeitgeber Dienstgeber präsentieren und
daher eine herzliche Einladung an alle
kommen Sie zur Leistungsschau lassen Sie
sich auch über die vielfältigen
Möglichkeiten beim Bundesheer
informieren und von der Leistung unserer
Soldatinnen und Soldaten begeistern wir
sind ein Arbeitgeber mit hunderten
Möglichkeiten und beten besonders in
diesen unsicheren Zeiten einen sicheren
Arbeitsplatz für leistungswillige
Österreicherinnen und Österreicher sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren einen letzten
Punkt möchte ich noch ansprechen weil er
gerade am Nationalfeiertag eines der
wesentlichsten äh Elemente ist und zwar
die Wiederbelebung der umfassenden
Landesverteidigung die zwar in der
Verfassung verankert ist aber viel zu
lange in Vergessenheit geraten ist die
wir endlich wieder mit Leben erfüllen
werden und so ist es wirklich
unabdingbar notwendig gewesen dass es
uns gelungen ist dass wir die
Wiederaufnahme der umfassenden
Landesverteidigung in die Lehrpläne
verankern in den Lehrplänen verankern
konnten und damit wirklich auch zeigen
können dass die Landesverteidigung
sicher nicht am kasernenzahn aufhört und
vor allem uns alle uns alle etwas angeht
denn das Bundesheer unsere Soldatinnen
und Soldaten die sind nicht bloß ein
weiterer Bereich der öffentlichen
Verwaltung nein das österreichische
Bundesheer mit seinen Soldatinnen und
Soldaten ist teil und ist in der Mitte
unserer Gesellschaft sehr geehrte Damen
und Herren ich freue mich bereits jetzt
auf zwei spannende Tage bei dem der
erste Tag insbesondere auch den Schulen
gewidmet ist auf zwei spannende Tage
voller gedenken und Feierlichkeiten zwei
spannende Tage für unsere Bevölkerung
aber zwei spannende Tage vor allem auch
für uns alle für die Republik Österreich
danke schön als nächstes ersuche ich den
Militärkommandanten von Wien Herrn
Brigadier Kurt Wagner um seine Worte
Sete Frau Bundesministerin Herr
Professor meine sehr geehrten Damen und
Herren als Militärkommandant von Wien
darf ich sie vor allem aus
organisatorischer Sicht über unsere
heurie informations und Leistungsschau
informieren sie wird nun bereits zum 28
Mal durchgeführt wir präsentieren das
vielfältige Aufgabenspektrum des
bundesjahres wieder in der Winter
Innenstadt an unterschiedlichen
Plätzen neben dem neuen Hubschrauber AW
169 den die V bundesmeisterin bereits
angesprochen hat werden fast alle
gepanzerten und geschützten Fahrzeuge
des bundeseres gezeigt also vom Leopard
über Ulan Husa Pandu oder Dingo an
weiterem Gerät werden wir wieder
Flamingo ausstellen das aufgerungs und
zielzuweisungsradar Mammut das Fahrzeug
da ABC abwehtruppe den Flugsimulator und
der Flugsimulator wird genauso das
Interesse der Bevölkerung hervorrufen
wie das ein Z ein Modell des Eurofighter
den Sie hier neben mir stehen
sehen der Bereich der Mittelstraße des
heltenplatzes also unter hinter uns wird
wieder für Vorführungen genutzt werden
diese werden unmittelbar an die
Angelobung und dem ausmarschieren der
Truppe stattfinden die
Fallschirmspringer des jagkommandos
werden die ersten sein es werden dann
die Garde folgen das Herre Sportzentrum
die Pioniere und
Infanterie traditionell präsentieren
sich bei uns auch die eine oder andere
Zivil Stelle diesmal ist wieder wie so
oft das Justizministerium dabei auch das
Mus Memorial präsentiert sich das
schwarze Kreuz zum ersten Mal hier und
die Wener Vikings werden sich am
helenplatz
präsentieren ein Wort zur
Sanitätsversorgung das liegt wieder in
der bewährten Hand der vier für Wien
undter Führung der
johannita auch am
sicherheitsfest der Stadt Wien sind wir
wieder beteiligt das am Rathausplatz
stattfindet dort wird die Pioniertruppe
ein pionierboot präsentieren so viel zum
Überblick nun ganz konkret zum Programm
wir sind wie Sie vielleicht auch sehen
mitten im Aufbau werden den auch nach
unserem Planungen morgen abschließen was
heute noch passiert ist die
Anlandung des AW 169 also davor auch ein
blackhw aber der wird wieder wegfliegen
das ist für nach der Pressekonferenz
nicht vor 11:30 Uhr vorgesehen danach
kommt das Eintreffen der panzerkolonne
als aller mechanisierten Fahrzeuge
Mittwoch
25.10 da ist der sogenannte Tag der
Schulen von 8 Uhr bis 16 Uhr hier haben
wieder Schülerinnen und Schüler die
Gelegenheit die informations und
Leistung schon im Rahmen ihrer Klasse im
Rahmen des Unterrichtes schon vor dem
Nationalfeiertag zu besuchen nun zum
Nationalfeiertag den Donnerstag selbst
protokollarisch beginnen wir wie immer
mit der ganzlegung durch den Herrn
Bundespräsidenten im weihraum um 930 Uhr
daran schließt die ganzerlegung der
Bundes Regierung um 10 Uhr an die
Angelobung beginnt um 11 Uhr unmittelbar
vor Beginn der Angelobung erfolgt den
Überflug von
eurofitn zur Angelobung werden etwa 950
Rekruten dabei sein und ca 20
Soldatinnen die Rekruten kommen aus
allen Bundesländern die meisten aus Wien
und aus Niederösterreich und
traditionell stellt eines der stärksten
Truppenkontingente die Garde und diesmal
auch die das
luftunterstützungsgeschwader aus
Niederösterreich nun z informations und
Leistungsschau sie beginnt um 9 Uhr
dauert den ganzen Tag der Rückflug des
Leonardo erfolgt um 16:30 Uhr und danach
fahren die gepanzerten Fahrzeuge vom
henplatz Weg um 17 Uhr wird die
informations und Leistung schau dann
offiziell
beendend ich bin überzeugt davon dass
wir für alle etwas Interessantes dabei
haben wir bittenen Bundesheer zum
Anfassen Informationen aus erster Hand
besichtigen von Fahrzeugen Waffen Gerät
Vorführungen der Truppe und Stationen Z
mitmachen ich darf da hier alle einladen
zahlreich zum helenplatz zu kommen und
darf sie die Damen und Herren bereits
jetzt versuchen keine Rucksäcke keine
Regenschirme oder sonstige gefährdete
möglicherweise gefährdete Geräte
mitzunehmen vielen
Dank abschließend darf ich den Vertreter
des ORF den Regisseur Kurt baumrz um
seine Worte ersuchen danke schön sehr
geehrte Frau Bundesministerin sehr
geehrte Herr Brigadier meine Damen und
Herren ich darf Ihnen im Auftrag von
Generaldirektor Roland weisßmann ein
paar Informationen über den
Nationalfeiertag 2023 im ORF und im
speziellen über die Live Übertragung der
Feierlichkeiten am heldtenplatz geben
traditionell steht das Programm des ORF
im Monat Oktober für besonders
rotweißrote Highlights diese reichen von
Filmen über Landschafts und naturtokos
bis hin zu kulturübertragungen und
Portraits wichtiger österreichischer
Persönlichkeiten ein Höhepunkt dieser
sehr bewusst österreichischen
Programmgestaltung ist seit 2020 die
Übertragung der Feierlichkeiten am 26
Oktober hier vom Wiener Heldenplatz der
Live Event der Nationalfeiertag ist
mittlerweile eine er vololksgeschichte
der besonderen Zusammenarbeit zwischen
dem österreichischen Bundesheer und dem
ORF das Interesse der Zuschauer ist
trotz frühen Beginn der Übertragung der
zipum ne außergewöhnlich groß historisch
gesehen war sie 2020 sogar die
erfolgreichste Sendung die jemals nach
einer Zeit im Bild um 9 Uhr gelaufen ist
aber selbst ohne coronaeinfluss
verzeichnete der F im Vorjahr einen
beachtlichen Marktanteil von
24% und vor allem bei den Jungen Zuseher
ist er freulich von 12 bis 29 Jahre
immerhin einen Marktanteil von
erfreulichen
22%. wenn man bedenkt dass in der
Zeitzone zwischen 9 und 13 Uhr im
Schnitt ein Marktanteil von 10% erreicht
wird so kann man schon von einem
außergewöhnlichen Erfolg sprechen auch
heuer beginnt die Übertragung um 9:05
Uhr nach der Zip im Newsroom durch die
wieder Rebecca Salzer führen wird ihr
zur Seite stehen in bewährterweise mit
profundem Wissen innpolitik Chef Hans
Bürger und Generalmajor Bruno Günther
Hofbauer zu Seite die Herren werden die
aktuellen politischen und militärischen
Aspekte rund um das her und den
Nationalfeiertag
erörtern Filmbeiträge von Stefan
rusowitzki wurde schon erwähnt werden
die zentralen Aufgabe des Bundesheeres
in den Mittelpunkt stellen die das sind
Schutz der Grenzen und kritische
Infrastruktur aber auch
evakuierungsoperationen und
Katastropheneinsätze hier im Heldenplatz
werden 14 Kameras zum Einsatz kommen
darunter zwei gräne mehrere steadycamps
Pumpen tragbare Kameras und Minikameras
Ziel ist natürlich auch heuer wieder das
Geschehen hier am Heldenplatz also
Kranzniederlegung Angelobung
fallschirmsprenger und den Überflug der
Eurofighter live in die Wohnzimmer
Österreichs in besonders guter Qualität
höchster Qualität zu senden der
wettergut muss halt mitspielen aber da
bin ich zuversichtlich das wird sich
ausgehen die Zusammenarbeit des
österreichchen Bundesheeres mit dem of
ist derfulicherweise seit Jahrzehnten
großartig und wird bei dieser Produktion
besonders unter Beweis gestellt in
diesem Zusammenhang darf ich mich für
die wertvolle Unterstützung namentlich
beim Major Norbert Link und vor allem
bei Oberst Bernhard opmann bedanken den
sich ich nicht Bernhard Deuser danke
vielmals für Unterstützung mein
besonderer Dank gilt aber der Frau
Bundesministerin Tanna die ihr
Versprechen vom Vorjahr tatsächlich
eingehalten hat mich bei meinem Wunsch
nach einer liveedone zu unterstützen und
sie hat mir und das war vor allem dem
ORF sehr wichtig in die Hand versprochen
das Gerät auch aus Ihrem Budget zu
finanzieren und das passiert heuer das
ist absolute Handschlagqualität vielen
Dank Frau
Ministerin es war auch nicht einfach die
behördlichen Genehmigung für diese
liveflüge hier am Heldenplatz zu
bekommen aber auch hier hat
dankenswerter Weise das möchte ich auch
gerne erwähnen der Herr Oberrat
Christian Gepp von der Burgh
Hauptmannschaft die absolute
Notwendigkeit meines Ansinnens erkannt
und es von Amtswegen ermöglicht vielen
Dank dafür in diesem Sinne hoffen wir
gemeinsam auf schönes Wetter und auf
eine dem Anlass entsprechende würdige
Friede friedliche und freudvolle
Veranstaltung vielen Dank sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren aufgrund der
fortgeschrittenen Zeit werden wir in
Kürze Zeugen wie hier ein Blackhawk S70
und in weiterer Folge ein AW 169 Lion
hier am Heldenplatz landen wird ich darf
die Pressekonferenz für beendet erklären
und für weitere Hinweise auf www
Nationalfeiertag 3 20.at verweisen danke
sehr